looking like an idiot too late already
started hello good morning good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel and literally after I
said um I'm going live Harris then went
wait one second too late real still
on it had happened we were doing it
so before we get into it this is our
100th Sid Trek live video 100th
that's weird man yeah um I only put our
like weekend ones I sometimes I put our
midweek episodes in this playlist but
yeah 100th so that's pretty cool um
let's see who's in the chat Sarah hello
Mr brain
pain
Laura 8 degrees I look like I'm dressed
for that but I'm not and oh that does
not sound
fun
yeah talk about some brain pain I
mean I'm more think of extremities pain
just make sure the bloody finger don't
drop off or anything for real um but
yeah hello everybody
um so we're just having a quick hangout
Matt couldn't join us he was doing
something Matt one t by the way um he
keeps spelling his name with two he's
realized it was a mistake um keep
yelling at me you're spelling my name
wrong you're spelling my name wrong then
he realized oh no he was spelling his
name wrong it's want he um probably um
we all know on this channel that I I'm
always right
or I have a massive
St throw my toys out the
FR um no
comment or hold the uh hold the Post
open as long as possible until I
win but effective it's an effective
strategy and it worked God damn it so um
we are going to be having a little bit
of a chat about I just remembered I'm
going to I'm want to put a post up
though it's something we're going to
chat about in a minute
so what you been up to this week uh
Young Harris other than giving blood for
like six days you there like oh my God
blood injected into my chin look the
what I have some of your blood injected
into my face and I've sprouted a a
really [__]
goatey right so I tell you why I haven't
shaved this right in a week this is a
week's growth by the way that's how
girly I am it's
pathetic um my I I hadn't shaved for a
couple of days and my wife um hey how
you doing bat boy Batman
howy um uh my wife went you got to shave
that off it looks ridiculous but she
went and I just like yeah I'm G to shave
off no no it look she really went on
about it and I went look you're pushing
me now I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm just G to
not shave it if you you're going too far
and she month of No Shave yeah she kept
it going kept it going and like think
right okay I'm not
shaving so you know the worst of it I
haven't shaved like this
sides that's just I just don't grow a
beard I have the worst beard in history
um my my lad want go um you're gonna do
member and grow mustache yeah
righten I think we should do the first
quarter of the Year all three of us grow
the best goatee that we can obviously
stormy and I have gotten a little bit
ahead of the curve here you're well
ahead but uh we we'll do a a a
concession bracket as
well
yeah I will get um the well I tried Ward
um you know like the uh M PE kit
when
kides you got involved well done you um
I get the you got involved in the
goatee um
the world of gois it's a good good world
as I can speak too
yeah just a second I am just putting a
poll on our main Channel a a poll what
kind of out of
the what kind of poll so Brad re needs
to run a new Stargate show not not that
type of poll um when you clean that pole
does it squeak
I'm not going to do the hand gesture of
how you would clean it because you know
we're a family show but bad I don't
think I've ever cleaned it but I don't
use it either so it's just kind of
here right okay so Brad Wright needs to
run the new Stargate show em emotion out
of the decision so not an emotional
decision a logical decision yes or no
post now why have I done that you might
be all going why is he done that it's
because that we never mention star
getting this channel so um
it's yeah it's it's a show M with this
big like donut thing um uh The Simpsons
Donuts um next week we are having
another one of our presidential debates
are we not Young Harris I believe we are
in this one brightens me just a little
bit yeah not true
but I'm I'm debating the the side that
is Brad Wright shouldn't be part of it
no Brad Wright breus
said I love me some Brad Wright and I
want him to be a part of it but I will
convince you that he doesn't need to
be well um uh ramunas has just put an
interesting comment in the in the thing
but we'll discuss that in a second um I
am I am arguing for Brad Wright that
Brad Wright should showrun and we will
add the preface of the was Show run the
show right not that he's just involved
we all want him involved so we're going
to change oh that makes my argument all
right makes your life a little bit
easier I think um signic so I've put
that poll up we're going to get that and
then we're going to see how we get on
with the um with the discussion and
we'll have a couple of polls between now
and then to try to get get a footing of
where we are good luck with that Harris
yeah I feel I've won this
already but as of now well we're gonna
make people think of course well I'm
glad that you just said uh the that I
guess the caveat that it would be him
show running and not necessarily him
just like involved in like even like a a
hands-off version of [__] kind of deal
um yeah not cons that changes the
argument entirely which is good because
we can all that he should be involved
he's earned the right to
did I freeze did you freeze someone's
Frozen you there you're you're stitching
a little bit oh let me double check that
my um I keep forgetting to turn my green
screen off even though I haven't got a
green screen behind
me who froze chat help us out help us
figure out
technicalities I can't see you very well
at all but is that because it's me my
internet going
or 35 people watching and
apparently yeah mine's been perfectly
fine so far up until that little freeze
right there which hold up let me open
this door for this cat real quick it
wants to go
outside well hopefully guys you can
still see me but yes tell us if if we're
having technical issues guys get into
the comments and tell us so oh I'm jerky
interesting it's you that I'm struggling
with so guys sometimes such streams
start with depressing as there is no
real progress on the Stargate reboot U
there isn't it just goes around around
the circles so if you would compare the
start of 2022 or with the start of 2023
is anything
different right yes it's
2024 that's different
um yeah we're not going to have a bunch
of strikes in
2024 different so besides the video gkes
but that doesn't affect that's not going
to affect Stargate
so yeah I've got a video straight after
this asking about whe the MGM slate
development thing that comes out in the
next couple of days will have Stargate
on it or
not
um and I I are we won't cut into that
because obviously watch the video and
comment on that so let's not go into it
too much but um I will say to this that
there is one I've had a couple of people
speak to me and they're saying that look
the plan is that they will be at San
Diego ComiCon in force for the Stargate
project and there are plans already in
place for it but I've had a couple of
people say to me it will be to announce
because it's going to be um the big
movie and thing but I've said and I've a
couple of people say like no it's not to
announce um it's to do the big sort of
like celebration thing up there so it'll
be announced already but then that'll be
them getting the cast on getting the
thing maybe even if if filming is
started maybe even you
know show us a few things so um
um I I which I think is more likely I
don't think we're going to have another
six months till San Diego ComicCon and
then not have announced it by then
they'll have announced by that um but if
it's a TV series um it is actually where
I normally stream from it is so like
there's my stuff in the background um
it's just I'm not using the green screen
so um and I've my desk has turned around
I turn my desk
around so um yeah your Wi-Fi today sucks
young haris um so let's see what happens
but um I think it's interesting that
they've shut up shop again in 2023 we
know they decided they were going to
announce this at San Diego Comic Con um
and it was going to happen and then
around March everything went dead
quiet um and nothing was coming out I
mean if I if you remember you guys I was
telling you guys last time but I was
I've always been told just before the
announcement it'll go dead quiet nothing
will nothing leak out they'll they'll
really lock things down sort of thing
because no one's the other thing is no
one's talking about it anymore so there
aren't any Whispers around town sort of
thing because it's been decided and they
know what they're doing so everyone
there's nothing to whisper about
something it's happened again it's it's
all gone dead quiet again so I'm hoping
that means something but we'll see we'll
see um
uh rashford scored yay it's 2-1 come on
you know and um but anyway that's not
what we're talking about today we've got
the video at 6 please watch that guys
put a thumbs up on it and tell me what
you
think St Harris you watch the end of
Monarch I haven't watched the end of mon
because I've got my grandson and he
won't let me so um can you tell us a
little bit about the final episode of
Monica and is it worth watching should
the lovely people give it a go I think
it is worth watching it's probably the
best of the series in my opinion
it it's it's the most action-packed for
sure um or maybe maybe not as much as
the penultimate episode but those two
episodes are definitely the most
action-packed which feels necessary
because I think you were kind of on the
same wavelength as me as like this is a
very well-made TV
show but it's boring as hell and they
could be doing a lot more with what they
actually have like considering the money
they spent on it that thing yeah um yeah
we are out of sync we've got a little
bit of a Wi-Fi issue over at Harris's
time but it'll some these things it was
fine a minute ago so I'm sure it'll
clear up I'm trying to get on either my
TV or my phone to figure out they
actually Ruff Rider just said Amazon
just laid off half of the company they
didn't and they've laying off 700ish
people
worldwide um it's it's not going to it's
that that's nothing compared to what
Amazon own and a big part of that is
Eastern EUR Eastern Asia anyway so it's
not quite as bad as it sounds but yeah
several hundred
it it was 700 right I just said several
hundred ah uh because I did it for MGM
and Prime which was just a lot it's it's
the
studios so it's MGM Prime uh
twitch um and a couple of other little
things that Amazon are involved in but
then they have offices all over the
world so that's not 700 people from
Culver Studios there's offices in
Britain there's offices in Eastern
Europe there's offices in eastern Asia
um it's so it's several hundred out of
thousands of employees so it's not quite
as bad as it sounds okay well that's
that's a little bit better yeah still a
good junk but it's not it's not
ridiculous sort thing but anyway um so
do we see
Godzilla in
monik I I mean you don't really see I
mean
you you you've seen up until the last
episode right yes yeah uh I might have
last I I might be too behind actually
okay well you you do remember seeing
Godzilla in like the middle of the
season right yeah okay well I I think
that's really the only time you see him
to that
degree was a flashback though was that
that was a flashback wasn't it no that
was that was actually happening uh
because that's where their dad the two
uh half siblings from across the world
are um Monarch we're doing we're talking
Monarch right now
um you don't see Godzilla in that same
pedigree I guess in the last episodes
but you you get his feel you know he he
weighs important upon the series like he
always does especially with KO Bill
Randa and um Lee Shaw getting monarchs
set up and and kind of to fruition in
general but there's not much monster
anything happening in the last episode
even though it is still the best episode
which is kind of odd they show you more
like they show you some clips and stuff
from like past projects and things like
that you do actually I take that back
you do get two or three really good
monsters in a much more subtle way so
you get more monsters but it's not
necessarily
um like I said it's not that pedigree
where you don't get to like hang out
with somebody that you want to be like
oh this is Godzilla or this is what M
yeah I mean you do see him but you don't
see him actually you do see him because
what I'm talking about you see him very
shortly he does one really cool thing
and I don't necessarily want to spoil it
for you um I will say do you care if I
spoil the very last scene for
you you worldwind go on oh spoiler
spoiler real quick y'all the last
literal like frame of the scenes in
Monarch uh Legacy of monsters is they
they I oh I don't necessarily want to
give you the concept of it either but
anyway
you see King Kong because I don't want
to spoil too much but King Kong is like
in the v in like the very final moments
of the season one of setting up the the
the movie then Kong do we think that
that's a bit of a setup for the Kong X
whatever it's called it it well no not
for that one I think season two of
Monarch will do something like that I I
do you want me to give you the concept
or do you want me to no leave it leave
it leave it let's talk about it when I
get chance to watch it those last two
episodes are where where you'll get that
concept and it does involve going into
like something I've been watching all
week the underworld just not the
underworld with vampires and werewolves
and stuff the the underworld vampires
all the vampires wear really tight
leather that was awesome yeah be in
sale if you had to pick monik or
Godzilla minus one what you picking oh
Godzilla minus one in a heartbeat that's
yeah yeah yeah Godzilla monus one is
genuinely genius even though I
I thoroughly enjoy the recent I I like
all of the Godzilla and King Kong movies
the most recent one I feel like had the
most potential and almost reached it and
the studio kind of kept it from getting
to the point it should have gotten to um
but I'd still choose godilla minus one
over any of them and and I really like
some of the new ones just for for
Blockbuster popcorn kind of Aesthetics
you know
but give me some they're definitely
cinema movies they they're really really
good
um I
I I'm watching um For All Mankind at the
moment it's my um it's my I'm at work
and I'm pretending to do things show at
the moment um so I I always have
something ticking over in the background
I'm working but I'm not that busy um
just I found the first season incredibly
boring but my God the second season
really um or towards the end of the
first season it really picked up um I I
I struggled with it at first um I don't
particularly like the lead actor
massively Joel K yeah the GU was in
Robocop and what have you yeah Rick flag
I'm not I'm not a massive fan of him um
but um it's his voice or something I
just find him a bit monotone and you
know
[Music]
um do you want me to talk about do you
want to to restart and I'll talk about
Stargate for a minute see if that helps
yeah sure that'll be easy yeah let's do
that and I'll talk about Stargate for a
minute all right while we're waiting for
Young Harris to come back
um we will talk about Echo as well I
I've had a
few we'll talk about starget quickly
then we'll talk about Echo when when
Harris comes back because I've had a few
comments about from a video I did a
couple of days ago where people
misinterpreting one or two things I said
but anyway um the difference between the
start of 2023 and start of 202 for
really that there isn't there's two
probably there's a couple of major
differences one I think the possibility
of a TV show is actually more real now
than it was in 2023 in 2023 at the start
of 2023 there was it was just going to
be a movie there was no um major
decision there was this idea of this um
franchise but it was really dependent on
the movie doing well um they were
looking at getting two or three Studio
and may maybe having a couple of
projects running at the same time but
they hadn't really gone beyond
um the the the movie the movie plan it
maybe even a Trilogy of movie plan
now the movie plan
isn't as locked in as as it was this
this may just become a um TV show maybe
with TV movies I'm I'm hearing that is
more likely now than it was before so
that's different but the main thing is
we're not going to have nine months of
strikes that are going to change this
decision this was decided this was going
to be announced at San Diego Comic Con
the strikes stopped it and then at the
end of the strikes Amazon had to have
three or four months getting back up to
speed and that's been widely reported
now that it actually did take Amazon a
bit longer than it took a few of the
other Studios to um to get back going um
so
[Music]
um raging J or J Smash video um it was I
was raging slightly uh Davey I was
really really not happy but we'll talk
about that in a minute
um and I think those that's the that's
the main difference now that 2024
they're confident they're running
through another big difference though
and this is related to the
movie studios have realized that the
cinemas are maybe not going to recover I
think the general assumption was the end
of 2022
2023 that 2023 would bounce back that we
would
see bums in seats at Cinemas similar to
preco levels and it's just not happened
other than one or two movies that have
done well 2023 has been a disappointing
year on the whole even though records
were broken by a couple of movies you
know Barbie and me
um oh Harris such a nuisance the young
young people today can't be Allied to do
anything
um it there's now a general acceptance
12 months on that it's not going to and
in fact the expectation is that there's
going to be even less bombs and seats
next year and actually that the US
Cinema Market is expected to drop by
about 10% in 2024 compared to 2023 and
overall 23 wasn't great so there really
is an issue um part of that big drop
though is going to be that there's going
to be less stuff being released because
of the strikes there's you know there's
that lag effect so that is going to be
part of it um but also there's just just
a generalization that Cinema is going to
really really struggle for the next few
years at least um there's an idea I
speaking to one person they said but
basically this happened with videos when
videos released streaming services have
got now so widespread and you got to
remember as well it was really covid
when we saw like Disney plus and a
couple of others um really kick in and
that's when we stopped seeing you know
or we started seeing Disney movies and
and fox movies as well on streaming
platforms really quickly and that trend
has continued um that people think well
why bother going to the cinema it's
going to be on streaming in a couple of
months we saw that with video releases
at first people stopped going to the
cinema because they were buying it on
they going to the video shop and instead
and going into the video shop became a
thing um there really
is it's but but it did spring back
people did swing back I do think though
there's a there is a point that one
person I was speaking to made that he
was basically saying that the youth
younger people today don't go to the
cinema to go out anymore they don't
socialize the same a lot of teeners
don't go out at all they socialize
through their games they socialize
through social media and things people
just don't go out as much as they used
to and that's a big problem because if
younger people aren't going to the
cinema older people don't particularly
either so there is a big problem that um
the younger people generation in
particular are so used to using their
streaming services and watching things
through their phone and that they just
watch they watch TV complet my my kids
watch TV completely differently I've
told you this guys before that um I got
Sky TV here in the UK it's basically our
version of
cable and I turned all the cartoon
channels on and I had to pay for that it
was an extra thing part of the bundle um
and the problem was I suddenly realized
after about six months I was the only
one watching it and they were young at
the time they were like seven or eight
they watch YouTube they didn't watch um
the Cartoon Networks hey we can see him
he's non blurry um so I realized I was
not watching cartoons um
anyway ah gaming and movies yeah gaming
and movies it's weakened so before we
get into well now we've spoken about
that you're Frozen
again young people
today no he hasn't he's not back he's
not it's
rubbish um so anyway that is a big part
of why um just going to knock him out
oh let's see if he reappears in a second
that's a big reason why I think the TV
series now all of a sudden has a little
bit more of a possibility than it did um
another thing that's actually good for
the TV series maybe not if you're in
America is that um MGM plus is actually
doing very well um it's actually
exceeded most expectations all the
things that they had in in um Amazon's
expectations particularly for the United
States of MGM growth they've exceeded it
so um I'm going to talk about this in my
video at 6 6 PM really to be honest but
there's um but you guys you you know the
lovely live audience you turn up for the
live so I can tell you um there really
is um an expectation that what now MGM
plus needs to push onto that next stage
and they are trying to push MGM plus
more
into new territories and things this
year and really trying to push it um is
that um they need that tent pole project
they need Stargate and if they can get
Stargate and MGM plus that will be the
the draw for um people you know guys I'm
always talking here about how each
streaming service wants that that TV
show that people will follow that people
get excited about and they'll follow um
Babylon 5 is one of of those shows that
will if Apple were interested in it
because they know people will go to
Apple to watch it um new projects are
great but if you can get something that
people already love and will be
interested to watch they will sign on to
go and watch it and the streaming people
know that the bulk of people that sign
on to a streaming platform never turn it
off if you can get them you keep I think
it's about four and five or something if
you can get them they never go because
we're useless with things like that
aren't we it's like that old joke about
your gym membership that nobody ever
uses you go on the 1st of November think
I'm going to buff up and I'm know I'm
Gonna Get Fit and then you never go um
but you carry on paying the direct debit
you know it's like um that that does
happen I'm still playing for Disney Plus
at the moment and I don't know why other
than Echo I haven't watched anything on
Disney Plus in ages but haven't turned
it off um I can't turn it off though
every so often I get a firefight itch
that I need to scratch that's one of the
few shows I'd actually don't have
um uh yeah warrior king is actually
sorry um warrior king is actually you
know is a really good sh actually I
really like it um they they need
obviously a tent pole in lots of
different genres though don't they
so um so yeah that's that's what we're
looking at at the moment um so so I
think actually a lot is different to be
honest the more you think about the more
you say that it's it is different
Amazon's organization of MGM is much
better now they've absorbed MGM
completely now MGM really doesn't exist
anymore it's Amazon MGM um they've still
got there a couple of offices but MGM as
as an entity doesn't really exist
anymore so that's been sorted this year
as well during the strikes
accelerated um Amazon owned more Studio
space now at the time of when 2023 I
think they only they control six I think
they own about a dozen now and by the
summer they're going to be owning
they'll be controlling they don't own
them but they rent them um another
doesn't so that's another thing that's
better now than it was then um so yeah I
think Amazon are
already
um Alex
Ryder I think babon 5 is going to end up
on freey I honestly think that if I'm
going to make a proposal if if babon 5
ever does get made it'll end up on free
um and what MGM will do with
Stargate it will go on MGM plus first it
it just will we might see the first
episode or like a TV movie on Amazon
Prime first um to excite people and then
it'll go to MGM plus um and then what
the chances are what will happen is when
season two of the Stargate series does
come out assuming they go the series
route or when they do the series Route
Prime will then show season one a couple
of months before season two comes out
and then you'll see something so you'll
get to see it on Prime but if you want
to see it sooner you'll have to go to
MGM plus um also there's going to be a
bunch of new movies and things on MGM
plus that you know
um no K Jennifer saly is is not at any
risk of being sacked at at Amazon she
really is um the main woman at at MGM um
it is true that there has been there is
Rumblings coming from Amazon about why
aren't they moving faster with the MGM
franchises that they're supposed to have
been doing all we had all these plans
and again the
strikes put everything back six months
and and meant that the studio wasn't
prepared but I know that um Mike the guy
V Jennifer s's main boss Mike Hopkins
was not happy that the studio wasn't
ready when they came back that
good no time Farm no no oh well there's
a weird noise and crackling but no now
you seem okay
now
so there some crackling noise live shows
are awesome last time you were having
your blood drained so you missed a live
show and now your internet's
rubbish no
um she did get um in trouble with um
we're just talking about Jennifer suy
um uh they are not upset about the money
they spent on rings of power which that
was one rumor that was going around that
Jennifer salaki was being blamed for
that but she wasn't actually she didn't
actually sign off on that um that was
Mike Hopkins who signed off on rings and
po um so um the one thing um they were
unhappy about though is the organization
at the end of the strikes that that Mike
Hopkins was unhappy about that and yes
Michael Wright is still at MGM he is the
head of MGM but he actually does he does
several things um he's the head of MGM
plus uh he's the head of two or three
other things as well he's got his
fingers in lots of Pies over am MGM
all yeah many pies um echo echo echo
echo I did a very probably the lest
thing I've seen in
years I couldn't help it I had
to um yeah man it's just ah it wasn't
that this guy right so so if you haven't
seen it I did a video a couple of days
ago I'm sure you guys will have seen it
all but I was Furious I was so angry at
this bell end um and I'm using that I I
I feel like that you're calling him a
bell end like insults bellends because
he's he was he was worse um and it
wasn't that he was calling the show woke
to be honest even though that I just
thought that's not fair come on um he
was
he he was racist sexist and disablist
and he and he used wording that I cannot
repeat on a live because it's
offensive um you would not call anybody
this unless you were trying to you know
he was he was it was really really made
me angry and he has been blocked he has
been blocked from the channel I don't
like people but he's gone I'm not having
people
being what he said guy hadn't even
watched the show yet either so how can
you actually form an opinion on anything
you don't know anything about yeah
exactly he just decided this is more
Disney crap and I I actually I think the
show don't get me wrong oh the pacings a
bit it could speed up a little bit but
um I I I'm enjoying it I'm enjoying it
um I think this feels more like
Netflix um Marvel than Marvel Marvel I
think it is I think it's more than that
don't get me wrong I still think Netflix
was better but it's more in that
direction yeah see okay so I'm I 36% of
me is Norse hence all of this but I got
the blood to prove it I got the
documents to prove it I'm a quarter
Cherokee and eighth shock to which means
I can apply for a casino one day um
but I'm not thinking about that at all I
don't know what you're talking about um
but I'm I'm a quarter chock t uh my my
birth Grandma who I really got to like
hang out with and meet and talk to
because I am adopted so I don't get to
meet everybody all time kind of deal but
uh I got to talk to her about being
choca and stuff this past year which is
really cool uh because she has all the
history about like everything y yada um
and and I I mean you you and I have both
been watching Yellowstone there's a lot
of great indigenous actors just
generally they have them in the show and
they utilize absolutely negatives per of
any of them it's it's the most I I I and
I got to preface this to too just
because we're in such a the the the
chock do culture between what if and
Ekko I think inclusion was amazing um Y
and and I I I have to preface this
because the internet's just the way it
is I I don't mind de actors I like death
actors the guy from Cotto that won an
Oscar I'm pretty sure he won an Oscar
fan freaking
tastic but ala Cox might be more of a
wooden actress than uh Natasha Lu biso
as Sabine like those are just two people
that they look great for the role but
they're they're not acting at all it's
just I mean it's so I understand that
acting especially from a de perspective
would be a lot more difficult because
you have to uh invoke emotion strictly
through facial expressions and things
like that but there just a't any facial
expressions coming off of aaka AA Cox
until about 5 Seconds everything that
happens it takes about five or six
seconds for her to realize what's
actually happening in the series which
it makes sense but it it screws the
pacing up completely and there's ways to
work around that in editing and it makes
it seem like deaf people are one step
behind people that can hear in the show
I feel like and I think that's is is
just a a wrong form of representation I
think at the end of the day like you
don't want to yeah this thing like
you're showing how cool this character
can be even with quote unquote
disabilities all right you're holding
her back at every turn for for something
that like and it's not only like in
action scenes and stuff like that it's
when she's in conversation she can't
actually keep up with the conversation
most of the time which sucks uh and you
you work that into it of course but damn
I that's not acting though is it though
like you said it's the editing surely
surely it's this this the director you
got have a word with because that could
be easily fixed I I I I usually yes I
would say opposite uh of that because
it's
an an editor H is doing that to make it
seem like that's actually happening
versus
um uh her acting well enough where it
just feels natural pacing wise that's an
editor having to repace her already slow
pacing things which if this is happening
in the TV show and it takes that little
time off that means it's
usually longer
uh in in real life and on the on set
acting
wise I I do I did enjoy eeko I just
didn't find myself caring for the show
at all by the end of it and and that's
not what I I should really um be feeling
by the end of the show I I did I I was
somewhere between General enjoyment and
uh just just not caring uh it wasn't a
bad only three episodes in because I've
um I have to work for a living and got
grandkids that demand my constant
attention
um but I I I don't agree with you I
don't see any issue with the with her
acting I think she's um she's not a
massively likable character but you're
not supposed to because she's still I
mean like said if you're still feeling
like that by the end of it surely it's
supposed to be a Redemption Arc and if
you still if I still feel like that by
the end but I don't particularly like
her character but that's because I'm not
supposed to she's supposed to still
be selfish and self-absorbed and you
know trying to deal with what's happened
and um but I feel um
um but um oh I forgotten his name the
guy that plays the Kingpin
oh yeah oh my God he's such a good actor
that he any anybody that is anybody he's
in the room with is go he going to
outshine he just is well when Al I can't
even say her name now alaka Cox is with
him I feel like her acting does elevate
to his level which is weird because the
rest of the cast is great but every time
I think my biggest problem is every time
she's anywhere else
where I I get it because once again it's
a de de actress the whole story is
following her but she's just not in her
own show all that much like a solid i'
would say probably 60% 70 even percent
of the show she's probably in but if
you're like that main character that the
title of the show is your name it should
be at least 85 90% of the show and I get
why they don't do it but it takes me out
of her story a lot of the time I
[__] it's
to um yeah no I i' L say again I haven't
really seen that as well but there is a
big cast here there is there is a lot of
things going on and like I said I'm only
three in so I can't you know I don't
want to go go on about it too much um
they did it does feel like it's been
boiled down it does feel like it's
cracking along it's they have spent some
money I think they Disney in particular
Marvel have gone on and on and on about
this is a re this is a new start for
Marvel MH um and I and I honestly think
they
have I said this shouldn't have been
called Marvel it should have been called
or Marvel Spotlight it should have been
called Marvel oh remember that stuff we
did at Netflix let's do something like
that because to me that's what this felt
like I wouldn't say this is on par with
the first season of Daredevil because
that is some of the best um Marvel we've
ever seen I thought it was
phenomenal um but it's on par with like
Iron Fist or something like that okay
it's on par with Iron Fist I don't think
it's anywhere on par with Jessica Jones
dared EV or Luke Cage honestly I would
say it's on par with Luke Cage for me I
never like Luke Cage though particularly
I would I wouldn't watch Luke Cage again
I would say it's better than Luke Cage
me um but I didn't like Luke Cage I
found the show quite boring I didn't I
didn't like it I didn't like the
character particularly I didn't like
Jessica Jones I loved the first season
of Jessica Jones
David ten is purple man I can't believe
they K him like come on yeah yeah yeah
oh they so stupid the first and third
seasons of Daredevil were brilliant the
second season was not great um yeah I
honestly
it's it would be um yeah I would yeah
the second season of Iron Fist was
better I did that a lot better A lot
more in part it was really really good
Iron Fist you know what the mistake of
Iron Fist was the casting of Iron Fist
if they' have got
somebody I don't know different I don't
know what it was about him that was just
wrong but I wanted to punch him in the
face all the way through and and I don't
I can't tell you why though the I like
the actor he's great in Game of Thrones
and everything else but it just didn't
work no it was just wrong um but then
you had the the the the girl that was in
it and stuff with that and that was
amazing Punisher was amazing um yeah we
had a lot of really really good Netflix
shows and I wish they hadn't stopped in
a way I wish they just I wish Netflix
and Marvel and Disney could have struck
some deal to allow them to continue
because they were great we've had to
have and we've had to wait five years
because that was in the deal with
Netflix that Disney were not allowed to
do anything from these shows for five
years well you saw that I think with the
Daredevil Born Again script that they
just said that they're bringing Deborah
andne wo and
uh uh oh what's his name it I can't
think of the actor's name right now uh
but the guy that played foggy Nelson and
they're actually bringing them back
because they weren't planning on that
originally which I'm very happy that
they are uh I'm not yucking on your yum
I don't want to yuck on your young but
why would you wh what puts echo in your
brain to the same I guess pedigree as
the Netflix series because that that I
think that's where probably my biggest
gripe comes from is it is TV mature
thing and I don't see why the hell it's
R of TV mature at
all I think it's I think the um the
action is more in line with what we had
the fight in the first in the first
episode The the fight between her and
Daredevil was was good that was a good
that was a good fight that was well
choreographed and um I've saw I I was
watching a live video and I had to not
going to say who it was but I had to um
uh unsubscribe I just thought then these
guys would they did a video last week
saying that they hated this episode and
then they said no now we're going to
watch it and they' not name of the video
is we forced ourselves to watch Echo
painful um and then they just went
through the whole thing and just like
and they were saying oh the choreography
this fight is rubbish I'm like no you
you dribbling they were like oh they did
this in John Wick and it was done better
I'm like what in in in a movie that was
groundbreaking a fight scene was done
better well well done noeds um but um I
I thought it was great
um and um but then it yeah then okay I'm
in the third I finished the third
episode now and I'm like yeah okay not
much else is there's been no more big
action sequences there's not a single
action scene there's not an actual
choreographed action sequence in the
show besides the Daredevil fight and
that pisses me off I I I I do enjoy the
show but I don't the thing that hurts me
is uh because I I did don't don't want
to Yak on your yum yuck on your yum
because you know people like different
things so it's not like not everyone's
gonna like the same thing always uh but
that's why you have a conversation and
and find the middle ground find some
compromise y
um I I I think the thing that I'm just
hung up on is that it's it's R to TV
mature and and while it pisses me off I
still think it's perfect in its own way
because this feels like Disney's version
of a TV mature it's like okay this is
your regular Disney Marvel t TV show but
it says [__] a couple times and it has a
little bit of
blood I don't I'm not I'm not agreeing
with you on that I think the tone don't
get me wrong it's still Disney it's not
as going as far as the Netflix seasons
did you know we're not having anything
like
um uh that EP that that oh that scene
when the guy wouldn't um he was so
scared of the Kingpin he headbed a spike
and killed himself and then when the
Kingpin the first time because all the
way through they were so good in the
first season of Netflix that the Kingpin
almost didn't seem like the bad guy and
then you saw him lose his [__] on that
Russian and take his head off the
cardor SE not sequen
scenes yeah you need to see a bit more
of that going on but
[Music]
um but I think it's more in that
direction anyway I'm not going to say
it's as good as anything they did there
it's as good as the bad
Netflix there we go the thing that I
think I'm hung up on is all the things
that I've said but truly it just doesn't
it keeps being compared to those first
couple Netflix shows and I feel like it
it is probably fairly on par with iron
fish season one at least but it's just
it just ain't the rest of those Netflix
shows but I I do think it's the perfect
thing for Disney to make to get them
eles into that field and into the
mindset to do that kind of thing they're
going in it feels to me like they're
going in the right direction yeah yeah
yeah they've decided to rewrite and
restart dead ofil reborn because they
need to go more in this direction they
need to go they need to go further in
this direction they need to keep going
on this is the path the right path um do
that scene like like comparison there
right the fight scene with the Daredevil
in this episode was supposed to really
Mar Mark the beginning of of Spotlight
it was supposed to be a big you know a
big fight scene compare that to the
corridor fight scene in the first season
was it episode three four of
Daredevil goes and gets the the kid
that's been kidnapped um that fight
scene down that Corridor was just
ridiculous it was I mean it
was I mean remembering this was uh 2015
was it something like that yeah about
that time that um we hadn't really had a
lot of the Big Game of Thrones episodes
by then the the shock episodes I
remember watching that I'm going that's
as good as I I've not seen a fight scene
that
good on on television before
ever you know and it was really before
streaming really kicked on it must have
been before 2015 2014 wasn't it must
been I'm trying to think because house
of cards came out 2013 Daredevil wasn't
too far behind it and House of Cards was
their like Flagship show for Netflix
um so it would have been 2014 or 15 I
think have a quick he was longer ago
than that but
still yeah uh TV series I love this open
SE I've just SE a picture for the
opening sequence as well God I love that
with the thingy dripping down and
everything yeah 2015 um I just the only
thing that made me think about that then
was like four years later we were in
lockdown that didn't seem right in my
head but yeah um I just I just thought
it was yeah yeah yeah I know I know what
you mean there um but um scene was based
on the raid I I um I think it was a
little John Wick as well John Wick had
been such a a year earlier had really
impacted and they they were I think they
were trying to sort of do a little bit
of that with the one continuous shot
sort thing um or you think it's one
continuous shot it's not but you think
it's one continuous shot um it was just
phenomenal hey Ken how you doing the
only Hall scene that I might like better
than that non-star Wars hallway fight
scenes would be um the season two even
though season two I agree with you isn't
as good as season one or three it it is
the perfect bridge the gap to bring you
into the Punisher show of course though
and the scene where Punisher has to
fight his way not out of the prison but
is fighting after like getting beat up
by whisk he just covered in
blood it's it's intense it's brutal and
and that's what echko being compared to
those shows made me think I'm gonna get
something like that especially with
Wilson Fisk being involved and stuff
like that and that's just nowhere near
what we got and for right or wrong
obviously we get Fisk in the hawkey
series is this better than the hawkey no
I see I disagree with I think it is I I
think the last two episodes are probably
better than Hawkeye's last two episodes
but I would take those first four
episodes of Hawkeye over the first three
episodes even the first four episodes of
echo any day of the week the first
episode of echo is literally just recap
and then the five minutes at the very
end of it is like now we're gonna get
over here and it's just her flying down
to tomaha yeah there was any um idea
with this Disney Spotlight and the idea
being that that you can just jump in and
watch this series and you don't need to
have watched all of the other Marvel
stuff to know what's going on that's the
idea of this Spotlight apparently that
it's it's going to be almost like almost
stand alone maybe that
attitude or that plan kind of did kind
of [__] on the first episode a little
bit because they thought well we've got
to explain it all then and I'm was like
no I don't you don't need to explain it
I watched hawy I don't you don't need to
explain all this and they tried to do it
in a clever way they tried to jump
backwards and forwards and do it but it
didn't that's what I said about the
pacing in the first episode was a bit it
went on a bit and I was like they didn't
need to do that but they did it because
of
this idea that this series can stand
alone and I'm like
H but it was it did go on a bit but yeah
half the episode was a recap though Saka
and that's a 37 minute episode yeah but
um but let's see um I I I think this is
a massive step in the right direction
for Marvel I will I don't want to say a
lot more than that I don't think saying
and comparing the shows to the best of
the Netflix Seasons isn't fair you're
right but it feels more like that's what
they've got in mind and that's a good
thing at the end of the day I think it's
a good show it's not necessarily the
it's not what I expected it to be which
is what I think is my biggest hangup but
I think Disney is gonna learn a lesson
in that and say like okay we're going to
do our Spotlight stuff and it's G to be
slightly different and you can kind of
watch it I guess by its own and all that
kind of stuff but yeah I I think this
will hopefully dial them back from
making claims
like or I
mean they're hyperbolism what I mean one
of the reasons they got people in the
seats at in general for the Marvels was
because they put Captain America and
Iron Man and everybody in all the
trailers and they're trying to trick you
to go into watching something and then
you feel tricked after watching it and
that's how I felt with Ekko by everyone
saying this is gonna be Daredevil this
is gonna be the Punisher this is TV
mature which is more than what Daredevil
and and Punisher were sometimes Punisher
was TV mature but I think Daredevil
started off tv14 so I was I I was just
expecting the world and it just wasn't I
would time I wouldn't let my kids watch
darel they were only like a 10 or 11 but
we watched the first three episodes and
then we were like we cannot watch the
boys watch
this I I think my one lad would have
cried back then but he was a bit he
didn't like violets next right I'm
really sorry about this guys but I
promised I would be off by 6 because my
my wife is looking after the grandson
and I thought it's only fair that she's
let me have an hour um I wasn't supposed
to have my grandson tonight but he um he
decided Well his mom and dad please let
us sleep please so I want to talk a
little bit about what we're doing next
week oh yeah so we are doing a
presidential debate on Brad Wright um I
am going to have a look to see if we've
had any votes on the uh on the thing
so what's what's the what's the
debate young young man what are we
talking about well as the uh the the
great uh expansion of the questions were
not the expansion of the questions the
consolidations of the questions uh was
given to us at the beginning of the
stream I'm I'm very happy to say that it
is should Brad Wright directly showrun
the new Stargate
series or should someone uh any any any
other person besides him possibly
get that chance that
role I don't think I'm going to need to
cheat on this
one okay
so to run a new Stargate show aemotion
out the decision 59 votes 88% um are
saying yes he should be in charge I
actually think there is an argument to
say he shouldn't oh I think there's way
more of an argument to say that he
shouldn't than there is and that I I say
that I know everybody that watches this
watch Stargate growing up I watched it
in the last couple years hindsight's
2020 I'm just saying
yeah well we're going to have that
conversation we are going to have that
debate it will be that um same format
we've got a few questions that we're
going to think I really want you guys to
um support this as well put comments on
think what what are the major points are
there questions you'd like us to try to
answer in that um we've already had a
bit of a think a we and and sort of
discussed a few things like Stargate
Universe does should we allow the person
that showrun Stargate Universe which was
a failure to um now showrun a new series
discuss and obviously that's the bulk
that discussion is going to be well
Stargate Universe was it a
failure come on
um so we're going to Pro yeah we're
going to be um I am in favor of Brad
Wright showrunning the new series and
Young Harris is um against the
proposition that he should show run the
new series
um this is
relevant in a way
[Music]
um in that there is stuff going
on
um I can't really say a lot hopefully in
the next couple of weeks we'll be to say
more but there there is going to be some
effort to support Brad Wright from um
the community we're going to be involved
in it and there's going to be um uh a
very serious push to try to one prove to
Amazon and MGM that one Stargate should
come back even though I actually think
that honestly from the people I speak to
that's a with that ship sailed but
anyway um evidenc in it and then
evidencing that actually Brad Wright has
that support from fans as well um and
we're going to be involved in that that
that discussion so this for me is the
start of that I want to have this debate
I want to have this argument and I want
to
um you know make both points because
there is an argument for
both
um and that's that's why I say that for
me take the emotion and this is
something you should if I was you if I
was arguing your position I would say
take the argument out take the emotion
out of the
discussion yeah and you've got to that's
how we've got to think because Stargate
fans want Brad or Rob Cooper or some
that involved
but maybe the world has moved on
so we'll see I want to say a couple
things but I'm saving it for the
argument saving it for the
debate um Dave um no actually
secular um I allowed Harris to
pick thank you very much so I would be I
am more than happy to argue either side
of
this um because I can see I can see an
argument either side and as we know as
well just love
arguing um we did that video uh on your
channel did we and I Greg that I did not
agree with at
all
I it was the start of every question was
like right I'm going to hell for this
one but I'm gonna say anyway um and you
know there was I I will quite happily
when we do these presidential debates I
will quite happily argue either side for
most things because I just like arguing
and it's healthy to look at both
perspectives too even if there's more
than two perspectives too just to try to
figure it all all around you know yeah
the illusion of Harris having a choice
precisely by me choosing was hey we're
doing this debate and the the choice was
so you're probably Pro and I'm probably
con right
yep
um I say there was a
choice and yeah the unions debate was
great I was I did
yeah um anything else like that that
y'all want let us know
um you guys will be the moderator but
Matt will be sort of moderating um as
storm is not very well he's he's really
not very well um he's got a um he's got
an infection in his penis um no sorry
just a bone he's got he's he's genuinely
actually sorry he messaged us saying
I've got an infection in my bone and I
went a boner infection immediately
because I'm a boy and I don't know how
to respond when someone I actually
genuinely care about is not well so I
have to make a stupid joke about it
instead so he's he's had constant penis
references so love um yeah um he's
really really not well he's he is
actually in
hospital but he supposed to come back
home tomorrow right supposedly the
earliest Tuesday is it's a national
holiday tomorrow yeah and what holiday
is it MLK Day Martin Luther King oh okay
you like what's that oh never mind I was
like murder death kill oh no that's not
right murder lick
kill so we don't have that um but
um U no it's not
gonorrhea and enus diseases are
hard that that's four little words go
all over the place there they that's
excellent well done
sir yeah yeah um but yeah um I will be
sharing with Brad Wright and now he
won't be moderating he won't be getting
involved in this but I will be letting
Brad right know that it's happening um
and the companion and um we'll see we'll
see what he how he responds afterwards
we we'll have a word I should have asked
Jenny Jen to come in moderate except she
wouldn't be able to sit and listen to us
speak for two minutes that's a good
point you have to get involved so um um
but yeah um it's it will be an
interesting debate it'll be an
interesting argument we had a lot of fun
with the last one we'll try and make it
a bit Slicker this time and be a bit
more organized because last time it was
a bit like Who's Talking Now I don't
know um and yeah
um M I wish I could get actually no I
don't no thank you um uh Darren and um
yeah they're they're nice guys but they
don't like getting involved to things
like
this um yeah they they just don't they
don't like it so it's not suggested to
them it's not what they do
um and
um yeah they're nice
guy sorry said Ken just posted argue
with an a
iBot
yeah bad thing is that's not out of the
realm of possibilities pretty soon
honestly we're not far off um I will out
argue anyone though come on um yeah I
just yeah I'm looking forward to R
Jackson hello sir a new Stargate needs
to be continu stand up and fight yeah
why not hey yeah I could message I could
message those guys they they're good
guys um but but no it's gonna be it's
going to be us anyway and um we we will
we will enjoy the argument and as I said
we'll we'll get it's this is but this is
hopefully going to be the first step in
a few projects in the next few months um
ac across a few which which dialate
hopefully gate World companion a few
other people will be involved in um and
and yeah we're going to we're going to
team up against this
thing we will make this [__] happen all
right I have to go so I am I am out of
here the my new video just is premiering
now so my YouTube channel is freaking
out right now it's like there two of you
um I wish I'd changed it really um Jay's
late he lost his computer
Pro a little bit
actually my wife said yes you can go
live but if you're not down here by six
o'clock I will kill you and so I am in
trouble already one minute ped um press
and hold what my phone keeps telling me
weird things so real quick just for the
chat before we head out of here for
these debates and stuff having a a guest
moderator may be difficult because we're
running it through streamyards and the
person who is the moderator has to have
the login for the account to get into
everything
oh uh it's probably always gonna be one
of us that's moderating but if y'all
have suggestions for obviously topics
for debates put them in chat but yep big
thing is if you want to do like shuttle
pod versus uh gate world or something
like that and we can work at making a
video or getting together like a little
debate something like that and hosting
that that could be fun but y'all let us
know stuff like that in the comments and
we'll think about that yeah yeah that's
a good idea why not
um hold and press to change your
wallpaper I don't want to change my
wallpaper right anyway guys thank you so
so much um we will see you next week we
will be having our argument um as we
always do um guest could be a neutral
body thank you s sci-fi Quest but
nobody's neutral it comes to Stargate
damn it
um for a movie sa monk why do you want
me to um block you from the channel I
don't and then and then come and find
you
and stab you no but um wants me to block
him don't know why
um and soar you got to be blocked as
well this is so David right under
they're all teaming up on you people
that hate my channel so much they want
me to block them
from they just love your channel so much
they have to come bring you the good
news yeah still 20 minutes left yeah
thanks not here so maybe not let's just
check before we go and no it's still to
to
to guys thank you so much we'll see you
later have a good one have a good week
we'll see you in the week we'll see you
on we will be on MCB probably Wednesday
yeah Wednesday for sure alrighty see you
then guys by bye yeah oh I pressed the
wrong button